it's it's a little bit dangerous to say
this on video but i think it's important
i know i can lose everything i have in a
minute
it's never ending desires i promise
i thought most
something's gonna happen either i'm
gonna be done or i'm gonna be
very big
faster
and where are we this is like the the
hollywood hills of of
the hisidim world world this is pomona
new york
not far from muncie uh up and coming
neighborhood
views of the city way back there i don't
think can be seen in the camera
and so tell me about this guy what's his
story this guy is
lipa schmelzer he is um one of the top
really really one of the big big boys in
the hasidic music
okay seen very friendly guy very
creative guy
i don't want to say anything okay just
okay just see if we just get a sweet
place
i think this is it so every
property i've been in this trip
everyone's had covet
so i haven't been wearing the mask
but i don't know here so we'll see
how's it going and you're about to meet
different sponsors
hello nice to meet you peter
nice to meet you how are you good no it
wasn't for me it's okay i wasn't sure
everybody here oh yeah yeah yeah have
you have you had it yet
yes okay then i'll add it and then yes
comes off you're gonna get your pay is
set up and then we're gonna go through
what you're doing here yeah and you just
moved here right i just moved here not
even a week
oh okay wow it's just a water process
it's a
so it's much better when they use gel
and go like this for now
and if it doesn't work out then i go
like this do both
go like this twist it around the finger
the pace first of all
it's an interesting thing because a lot
of this stuff is
is a few hundred years old maybe at most
like the black
coat yeah and the pace is it from
straight from the bible i don't know if
i could get away
with it but it's working on you really
well yeah thank you so much
so uh thanks for the compliment
hey shimmy so i told my children english
because i'm
believing that they should know you know
there should be there should be there's
a hebrew word
which means that you have to have the
torah
and you also have to have uh be normal
between people among everybody's eyes we
teach them english
now you knows so well english he says i
want to start talking
because i don't want to forget my father
by the way
and uh he passed away he was in the
concentration camps
yeah he came he became very very ultra
orthodox acidic
he brought down 12 children i'm number
11. i think that gives the story more or
less yeah
how long was he in the concentration
camp the exact date
i don't know if i know right but he was
there he was thinking he was in camp he
was in hungary
and he was on casta strain so the
custard strain of the whole thing
controversy with money with the with the
nazis
so in the middle of their way to take
them to switzerland they put them in a
bergen bells in ghetto
they wanted to take them to auschwitz
and they were negotiating with money in
the end of the game they went out and he
went to switzerland
and uh thank god they came to america
this is unfortunate
what did he think of america
so it's an interesting question because
my father
it's a little bit dangerous to say this
on video but i think it's important
because i think for
secular people to understand the mind of
the old generation of the people who
came out of the holocaust is important
my father looked at everybody who was
not like him or not jewish
he was traumatized and he told who knows
who is the next
who's going to do something next and the
next generation
knows no there's a lot of nice people
and it's nothing but i think that
the reason why so many people live in
communities so tied together
people can tell you all types of nice
reasons but i think a lot has to do
with the reliving of the the because the
founders
who founded these communities are people
who came out of ghettos
right and i think it has a big impact
right the younger the generation is
people can like my father would never go
on camera like this yeah he did it for
me once
but like if i tell him you want to
interview him he would be like no
you know until a job really moves but
i'm gonna do
a lot a lot of uh a lot of great apps
like uh
it's like your own museum down here yes
there's gonna be it's gonna be a museum
these are letters my father wrote me
when i was a boy so i
i kind of kind of put it together some
are some are straight someone opposite
because he's not alive
he looks down from the other world so
how do you think your father was
obviously traumatized from his
experiences in europe you you were born
here
you didn't have the same experiences how
did it change the question do you think
it's transgenerational like it's going
to be in
yeah i think all our trauma's in there
for a while right yeah yeah it's like in
the dna
it's a fact it can't even be different
because uh
let's just think about it for a second
okay yeah time heals and also people say
okay don't bring me back all these
memories don't it's not true
but if you go to the beginning you wanna
you look at me while i looked and you
say
you had three hundred dollars and i only
had ten dollars you don't know where it
went
but you go back since the morning i had
a coffee had breakfast
i went to home depot at the ball okay
this is where my money went
so if we go back just if we go back
chronological
we think my father was 16 years old yeah
and
his father passed away in in montgomery
and other
an army camp with the hungarians he was
trying to help out it was like an army
and he came here all along he came with
his mother and one brother but all along
without a father without most of his
family like his uncles everybody you
know
he became different and he looked for a
job and he didn't know the language and
before you know it he's married and
he's bringing down children i'm one of
the children yeah so it's
just mathematical it's very simple to
see that it has an impact and it takes
a few generations to for people to to to
see things different in a different
light
right so your kid how you raise your son
yeah
if you look at this this is me
graduating
from columbia university but right away
columbia university yes
but right away i mixed it up with so i
thought most i thought most
acidics don't go to a higher education
exactly so i had a different
journey which i didn't want to go into
okay but
uh i had a different journey and i and
and i and and you know we had
we have our ups and downs and now i'm
very integrated in the community
and i can i i should say that even my
journey helped me be
very strong now the community what do
you mean my journey like you went away
from the relationship
a little bit more modern let's just say
okay but now i'm very in the facility
community
but i think even going to colombia the
not for everybody has the same affair
but for me
it affected me in a way that i saw my
roots i saw i'm never going to become
chinese i'm never going to become
italian it's far like i'm between all
these people but i'm always going to
stay a jew i'm always going to be
this is how i'm looked at this is just
the way my heritage is you're gonna put
my father
in the middle like he wasn't so happy i
go for education and then i put
he was studying this all day did he ever
support you in the
in you know in the in the education he
wasn't so into it but
he always tried to give me good words he
wasn't a big musician he wasn't
really living on this in this world he
was like really living with god
but i think it's all part of the story
but part of his journey that
he went through he never said shiver he
never had a funeral for his father he
never had closure
his father is in the mass grave i never
shared this in public
i went for for like a you should say a
workshop you could say a therapy
workshop
and for three days and there was a lot
of tears so i took all the tissues or
the tears
and i glued it and this is all the whole
painting is made out of the
tissues of that always yeah you can feel
it
even and then this is like a cup of wine
because i said to god it was right like
before my whole
uh the transition back in the hasidic
community very strong
i said hashem you know take my tears and
take it into to to to
castrate to a couple of blessings it was
all after my father passed away i had
like a if you want to go mystical
i once almost drowned i went to florida
to to
to take a cup and purify before pastor
where it's a whole other tradition
and it was quicksand pulling me and my
son pulled me out
i almost died and then the the
the police and the area told me you
can't go into that water they have like
um
i don't know if crocodile not crocodiles
um alligators
and about a few weeks later i had a
charger in my house
putting too close to the bed it has a
mat i had a metal wire and i woke up
the wall was on flames my mattress my
blanket i had a whole house empty out
all my kids
and i ran out and i said god everything
is going like wrong
like my money and i almost burned and
almost drowned
something's going to happen either i'm
going to be done or i'm going to be
very big you know i don't want to say
the word big but very and things stand
around for me and now i'm very busy and
very popular
and i say how many years you've shot i
say this because i've seen the other
side and i know you can't be a big shot
when you're popular because it's not you
god can take it away any second and i
hope it will give it to me
so how do you keep the humility from
that lesson from that lesson
i've been through i will never judge
another person again
i was always humble to speak to people
nice but
i am in a place where i know i can lose
everything i have in a minute
and i'm asking hashem that he should
give me every day another opportunity
it's like when i look at this beautiful
house i want to say thank you hashem for
giving me the house but then i say no
thank you hashem for letting me have the
house today why
because it's a mortgage if i can't
afford the mortgage for seven months
from now they'll take away the house
yeah so that means thank you for having
me for letting me have the house today
yeah and that's the spiritual security
alarm
i learned that a few weeks ago music
music
i'm calling this i'm since i'm about
seven eight years old
i know the recording studio okay at age
it's time to for me to change that from
a studio to a studio
and this place i'm going to learn i'm
going to dive and i'm going to pray i'm
going to meditate i'm going to write
music
so this is one corner is music one
corner piano one corner is the books
one corner is learning that's what i
like to do that's why i like to look at
this place
can you can you play anybody yes yes
so let's see what i got
[Music]
on the background that i'm thinking i'm
embarrassed because i don't recall
having this piano
but then i'm realizing i took this
playing in the background
so uh besides this we can learn
something from this because this is how
our mind plays today
it used to be that you can be focused
and now you can be focused because
your mind is is all the time and
it's here it's there it's everywhere at
the same time you know and technology um
could be a disaster or it could be an
advantage
yeah i think it depends how i use it i
mean i don't know if i would ever be
with human conversation without
technology so look i don't
come from san francisco and then we see
what people we have different
looks but really we're human beings so
the only way to get it really is to go
into that other world
yeah and that's what technology is
allowing allowing us to do because i go
into the other worlds that most people
aren't going going to
i capture them and then they can get
there virtually
yes and i talk to you i get inspired by
[Music]
you
you're constructing this on the fly
right now yes
okay so that's a rhythm
peter peter came to my home on friday
it's right before shabbos and it's
usually my day
but i will give him give him give him a
few words from the community
to bring unity i want to utilize that
opportunity
oh peter peter peter you will experience
the shabbos shabbat scotty dish
oh shall the squiddish means holy
and pure you will come with all the
shula shabbas
peter
you will lead us like a leader
you will show the world we can come
together
now let's have a good shower
good job
how do you do that i think i know i
think i know i always it was just
channel three
somehow my mind is very fast
okay leave us so i just want to finish
with one thing i want to finish by
saying that first of all
i to i want to grow and learn to to love
myself and love others and appreciate
life
i have so many blessings but we have a
thing we call the it's a horror it's
like in the
evil inclination it's in english maybe
like i have this beautiful view
but i have these four trees blocking the
water a little bit
so i'm thinking i need to ask the
neighbor if he can let me shave it
a little bit and then i'm thinking what
if you're not gonna let me
so i'm not gonna have denies you i'm
saying you have the most magnificent
view but you're not thinking about the
trees
because it's a never ending story yeah
and then you have a window thinking i
should have a whole glass window
it's never ending the desires it's a
good thing because it drives us but we
have to also keep it humble
and then i want to say that they have
nice animals here it's like we're living
in a mountain we came into their
territory
in the summer we have black beers wow
and i'm afraid a little bit
so i didn't want to move here because of
this it took me a whole year to decide
that i love the view so much
that if there are black bears i hope
they're not going to bother me and
people die from cars and people die from
strokes and heart attacks and i hope
i'm not going to die from a black bear
and i overcame that fear so i'm happy
thank you hashem for giving me this
beautiful view thank you hashem for
sending me rabbi science thank you
hashem for sending me peter
thank you hashem for giving me this
opportunity and to thank you
publicly thank you thank you hashem for
watching this
where can people find your work they
already know you but those are the
google leapfrog google they can google
my my videos they can google
my youtube videos they can go on itunes
and spotify and thank you again brother
for lining this up without shlomi we
wouldn't be here
and if you want to support this channel
i have a patreon link down
below do direct dming uh you can
support however you want thanks for
coming along
we got to get going because we're off to
uh chavez yeah leap is going to be there
yeah we've just gonna be at chavez okay
next video will be chavez
okay thanks for coming along
so now that i don't have the synagogue i
don't have the show i keep this as a
memory
because in our hearts we all have
we all have a show it's called the
mishkan in hebrew